mind your decisions i'm presh tallwalker
a cube with an edge length of three
is stacked with a cube with an edge
length of two and a cube with an edge
length of one as shown where two of
their faces are aligned
imagine drawing a line between opposite
corners in this diagram
the question is what is the length of
the line contained inside the middle
cube
this was suggested to me by email and it
came from the source d-quant
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try and when you're ready
keep watching to learn how to solve this
problem
[Music]
we will solve the problem using similar
triangles and separately solve it using
coordinate geometry
let's get started with similar triangles
first we'll consider this right triangle
we'll calculate the length of the
shorter leg as follows the shorter leg
is the diagonal of the square whose side
length is equal to three therefore the
shorter leg has a length equal to three
times the square root of two
the longer leg will have a length that
consists of lengths of three
two and one so its entire length will be
equal to six
we want to calculate the portion of the
hypotenuse that's opposite this two
in order to do that we'll calculate the
entire hypotenuse length using the gogu
theorem
we substitute in the values and then we
calculate and simplify that the
hypotenuse has a length equal to 3 times
the square root of 6.
now we have three similar right
triangles
as such the hypotenuse
will be divided into a ratio of one to
two to three
therefore three times the square root of
six will be equal to x plus two x plus
three x which means it will be equal to
six x
consequently we divide both sides by 3
to get that 2x is equal to the square
root of 6 and that's the answer
let's now solve the problem using
coordinate geometry
first we will set up a coordinate system
as follows
since the bottom cube has an edge length
equal to 3 we can label one corner as
the point p with coordinates 3 3 and 0.
the other corner we will label with the
point q and it will have a coordinate of
0 0 6.
we'll first describe the vector p q
that goes from the point p to the point
q by subtracting the relevant points
we get that pq is equal to negative 3
negative 3 and 6.
we can then describe a parametric
equation for the line going through pq
by adding the point p
plus t times the vector pq
we then add coordinate by coordinate to
get the following equation
we want to figure out the portion that's
contained entirely inside the middle
cube
notice the intersection of this line
with the plane z is equal to three will
give us one endpoint of this line
segment
if z is equal to three that means six t
is equal to three
consequently t is equal to point five
and the point we're looking for will be
equal to 1.5 1.5 and 3.
we then want to find the intersection of
this line with the plane z is equal to
5.
this means 6t is equal to 5 which means
t is equal to five over six
we substitute into the equation for the
line and we get the point point five
point five and five
we now can solve for the length of this
line segment by using the distance
formula we substitute in the coordinates
and then we simplify
it'll be equal to the square root of 1
squared plus 1 squared plus 2 squared
and this simplifies to be the square
root of 6 and once again we get the same
answer
it's a pretty neat problem for
three-dimensional geometry
thanks for making mind your decisions
one of the best channels on youtube as
always thanks for watching and thanks
for your support
[Music]
[Music]